the king is dead PewDiePie is dead long
live our new Indian overlords we welcome
you the new kings of YouTube meaning if
you want me to do a collab I'm more than
up for that
PewDiePie rejected us for the podcasts
anyway [__] em [__] them if you want to
come on the podcast a series you're more
than welcome yet we love you our new
rulers of you choose how much you rate
PewDiePie why you [__]
never whatever look it's not healthy
days all over again we love you to sees
if you guys could come and do the dance
thing you do because it's really growing
the girls women aren't watching now the
t-series women aren't watching you now
all right if your silly little chain and
your weird little stripes
[Music]
so this week there's a fellow on YouTube
called Matt Watson found some videos of
kids that had comments that look like
they were from Peters because of that
they were saying time stamping things
that may be right the good bits for
Peter was for example he raised
awareness of that let the YouTube know
hashtag YouTube wake up was what he did
by all accounts YouTube we're welcoming
the issue you know so you're thinking to
yourself at the time when you first hear
about that job well done me clean up
YouTube it's obviously not gonna be an
easy thing but he's raising awareness
good on you great news
next news story move on this man guys
done good that wasn't enough for what
the [__] he realized that this was a
chance for him to blow on YouTube yeah
so he starts saying all all the news
channels hunt up the ad companies
running ads on YouTube tell them small
the ads from YouTube on what these
Martin is what you don't understand like
because of that tiny minority of people
doing bad things you're going to [__]
the entire system for all of us yeah it
deed said look this isn't what I want I
don't want to hurt youtubers but I just
feel so strongly about this that I feel
like this is the right course of action
to take yeah then you might be the same
all right I can see where the guys can
he man yeah but you said [__] all
youtubers get real jobs cons didn't make
him look like a good guy here's the
problem YouTube is full of and I'll say
this like lightly so righteous pricks
and this righteous prick took it too far
credit to keemstar he made the best
video about this in my opinion
say we can do it so as I'm watching more
and more of Matt Watson's live streams
it becomes very clear that this isn't
about stopping the PTO's and this is
more about getting as much attention as
possible but when Matt saw my tweet this
is what he said on his live stream
rolling care more about money than you
do about protecting people you know so
what if it affects you but work at
[__] KFC bro you care more about your
money this guy I don't like this dude
you know get a part-time job
I just thought dude saying he has a
point well what is the point here the
point is by ruining YouTube and [__]
everyone's money up you're not actually
gonna stop Peter files from watching
videos of kids now all you're doing just
get back to daily monetizing those
videos and stopping the people uploading
those videos from making money from them
and I understand that that you have to
raise awareness to the issue but by
taking the money away that doesn't cure
any issue now and certainly by taking
the money away from youtubers like me
and keeps on whoever else that I'm going
to cure anything all it's just gonna
hurt the platform so you just said I
don't like this guy
right [__] him yeah now keeps offers to
talk to him let's see how is that you
changes right brother I don't have a
Twitter I'm literally so I will I will
make it Twitter when I come home I would
love to talk to you I don't think you're
a bad guy I'd love to talk to you I'd
love to get your opinion I don't know
this guy apparently a minute ago but now
love to talk to you love to talk to you
brilliant now the attentions coming Oh
funny attitude change there keemstar
doing what he does best did some digging
and oh did he find out some [__] about
this guy he said I don't have a Twitter
oh you were lyin bro you were lyin and
he has some old YouTube videos and he's
a little creep now on this video from
Matt at about 2 minutes and 19 seconds
there's a schoolgirl walking down the
side of the street and Matt pulls up to
her in a car honking the horn asking her
if she wants to do an adult film with
him
no no no no no no video she's terrified
she's [__] terrified you're literally
told about this [__] when you're a kid
dawn talk straightened out told scratchy
ones in cars like that she's probably
[__] terrified the special guys he
look like know exactly that's worried
odd companies have started pulling their
ads from huge and people are losing
money because of this [__] clone yeah
so one of the people affected by this ad
pocalypse - Yessica Ballinger is a
mother who is tweeted at you - she's
very pissed off block capitals my
five-year-old son does gymnastics
hobbies 3 confident boy YouTube have
deemed it not advertiser friendly why
she pissed well she makes a lot of money
out of posting the kind of videos with
her kids in or whatever she does like
hundreds of thousands of years Hawking
because they're deemed family friendly
they don't sway like we do and all of
that it's probably making her a lot of
money so YouTube are saying because of
the kind of comments that are found in
these kind of videos they're just de
monetizing Wow on the one hand if you're
a parent and you want to put a video out
of your kid
you should have every right but on the
other hand Peter files exist yeah is a
fact of life unfortunately and therefore
you need to make a decision and think if
hundreds of thousands of people are
watching your child consistently like
they seem to be here there's a high
likelihood that there's some horrible
[__] watching those videos and
the fact that you're making money out of
it and relying on that kid and that kid
not being consenting as an adult for a
life where you are made a celebrity
before you even know what celebrity is
there's something also not cool about
that because you're forcing a kid down a
road to make money out of that kid when
it hasn't even got the wherewithal and
the fourth or if it's life to say do I
want this for myself I am a thighs to a
degree that she might be relying on this
money and it's been taken away out of it
because of a tiny sliver of bad people
out there on the internet which is not
controllable you know some social medias
you have to be 60 and 80 you know
whatever the [__] the sign I think
Instagram might be something like that
maybe YouTube should have a simple
see where Charles built around a
personality that personality should have
to be at least 16 you know this one may
also be looking at it as the money I
earn from this goes into a college fund
for my kid
how's inter goes into the travel to get
me to the competition's for the
gymnastics so much better recovering
from his surgery what if that pay for
private surgery for all these things you
think well this goes into funding my
child's dream I want them to be
maybe I mean the Olympic chance maybe
they can go and compete somewhere maybe
a big brand you'll see it and then
they'll pay for him to go to college
you'll pay for him to go to a private
school or whatever I think the other
side of it is we've created the internet
and we want it to be perfect or we want
it to reflect the society that we want
to have I think we have a bit of a
problem in society that we ignore
pedophiles rapists all these things and
try and sweep them under the rug too
often we have to work out as a community
where the YouTube wants to represent
real life or whether it wants to
represent the bubble of people who they
choose to be on YouTube and it can't
have it both ways you can't be a bubble
and represent real life and at the
moment that bubble does not benefit
creators or advertisers they both get
[__] when someone like Matt comes
along and provides misinformation to the
masses it's that simple
he screwed people because he misinformed
one of the companies who's pulled out
this Disney the irony of Disney pulling
out of YouTube because of here the files
reportedly being in the comments on some
of the videos of kids Disney were
actually employing pedo files to work at
Disney World you can see Mickey Mouse
being arrested of all the only night I
think they should have now people were
to treat Disney the way Disney have just
tried YouTube every like say I will you
employ Peters we're not going to say Toy
Story for then [__] [__] Buzz and
Woody like I was definitely people all
along do you not I mean you just the
police looked at him and went here isn't
it those little hands tiny hands big
body do you know the big lesson this
week the world's full of hypocrites or
Kelly has been charged with 10 counts of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse at
least nine of which involve - it's just
shocking how he was able to get away
with it for so long that's the main
thing celebrity obviously the Michael
Jackson documentary is coming out soon
which we don't know about the director
of that has recently come out and said
he believes it could lead to an
uncovering of a
of people coming out very similar to the
Jimmy Savile yeah you always have to
look at the Lance Armstrong story
remember when Lance Armstrong was outed
as a drug truth but what I mean by that
is one person got pissed off pissed at
Lance and went I'm just gonna blow the
whole thing up and then everyone got so
this poor girl got it on her face fifty
got a picture of everything she left his
best friend or whatever he booked
ordered the picture she now AWS him
money from the core case and he's still
publicly harassing her for the money
what part of [__] give me my money do
you not understand this is a public
shaming of someone which I don't dislike
the only person whose public shaming by
moving on the NYPD has confirmed to pix
11 News that there is an internal review
into Deputy Inspector a Manuel Gonzales
told his officers during roll call
referring to Queens rapper 50 cent to
quote shoot him on sight
this cop is [__] himself over because
now 50 cent knows that he said that and
there was obviously some cops arrive who
did not agree with this shooting 50 cent
on side yeah they've dogged him in it
basically and now it's being exposed 50
is making this man's life hell a misery
right he doesn't give a [__] that he's a
cop he's saying [__] like this Manuel
Gonzales is a dirty cop we wouldn't say
it's so clear if they weren't good cops
around when he did this the problem is
easy dragging the name of other people
through the dirt when you know him so
well after we've seen him for so many
years now you can imagine important it
was into laughing out loud as you right
there man well here's a dirty cop
thank you how funny he is this guy's
been a 30-year veteran of the NYPD and
now all he's ever going to be known for
is that wait for a black guy to deal
with cops in America's keep it all out
in public make sure everyone can see so
that when if or when something happens
people know well fifties done that so
this was a statement given by the NYPD
I guess no needle stand investigators
charged 50 cent
with aggravated harassment of a police
officer
well fifty said was a threat to law
force at no point has this man said why
so he says let me talk about the first
50 cent made then doesn't ever give an
example of that because all fifty is
done they said this guy is the dirty cop
as far as we know yeah publicly publicly
if he's done something privately then
he's cleverer than you or because you're
[__] dumb enough to get caught
true as a cop you should know about but
doing things privately doing bad things
privately does not make you a better
person it doesn't but that's not what
this is about this is about evidence and
what we've got to play on yeah and
ultimately the cop is a [__] idiot
any as he's being exposed to he was
stupid oh yeah yeah and they're saying
this is a harassment well you know what
is harassment threatening the shoot 50
cent on site that's pretty harassing all
I'm saying is they're both [__]
so this [__] has gone viral of Barack
Obama eyeing up this fine woman and he's
getting a lot of criticism for it you
know you should know better you're a
married man what are you doing I don't
even know if he's really looking at it's
publicly accepted that that's what he
was doing I know you love Barack but
he's clearly looking at her looking at
her ass and who could blame him she is
[__] love what do you think of him
doing this he's getting a lot of
criticism especially off women out there
but Barack Obama's looking at the
backside of a girl then I think he's
wrong he should not be doing that that
is bad does your little here or looking
at an ass disappointed you no no it's
more that I want to see why a woman no
caught in the puppet well so it's no I'm
saying it couldn't happen it's what I
want to look at his oh look at his eyes
Mulder it adore us what I'm saying is if
Barack Obama's media trained he is an
ex-president of the United States
dude to be oh no you don't have to be
that great to be president look at
trouble why is there no clip of this oh
yeah oh she up there you go me oh you're
having a good old look son who can blame
him getting hammered married man how did
you do this how else is he gonna do 27
years as a married man sometimes 27
minutes after being with a woman men are
thinking about different women let alone
20 years I used to take in a mental
picture for later women
get the [__] off Barack Obama's box
y'all gonna do 27 years as a married man
you meet a lot of other women that is a
minimum to get through that because he
is supposed to already look at Michelle
no but I'm saying is he's doing sorry
he's not lying that's not the point of
what I'm saying what I'm saying is he's
publicly being disrespectful to Michelle
if that's because sometimes when you say
a woman's our store as well as men we
switch off general I mean what you're
saying is if you don't get caught that's
okay you're a local oh right that's the
rules
and that's true news Alex Jordan how is
still going a Joe rule of course he is
who gives a [__] at this point sure my
issue here if that's Joe Rogan's
daughter she's like 20 the governor
photos it worries me that Alex Jones is
sort of looking that is me it's doable
that's a bit weird does it also worry
that on hand Alex Jones has a gallery of
joke pictures of Joe Rogan's daughter
this is weird I knew he had daughters I
didn't know you had a step from a
previous relate so his his missus had a
kid from a previous relationship which
is this girl it took the Joe Rogan to
reveal the sort of stuff about himself
and Alex Jones has taken it upon himself
to reveal this he's on his high horse
what does his daughter called blacklight
she's a beautiful young life mixed-race
me what does she call it when her
stepfather says that black people are
Apes and that they're Planet of the Apes
so this is an old clip from a long time
ago that alex has brought up did Joe say
this here's the clip I'm talking about
him on the podcast but my buyers DNA of
the Apes and we're gonna go see Planet
of the Apes so look on the iPhone app
and it says okay take me to this one and
the guy goes okay goes that in a good
neighborhood
okay barely speaks English he takes us
there we get out and we're kicked leaves
we walk into Planet of the Apes we
walked into Africa dude we walked in the
door and there was no white people
everyone knows I'm a [__] huge Joe
Rogan fun and to the point where people
tweet me oh you think your organ you
know what near as good as clearly it's a
disappointing comment for me and despite
the fact that it was a long time ago
podcast was just three guys getting high
in a bedroom and it's obviously evolved
and he's evolved and I don't think that
this is the kind of comment that shows
what inside him is a
right it was an off-the-cuff flippin
silly comment he really should address
this land he should apologize and
explain it at the fact that he has got a
stepdaughter who's mixed-race would tell
you what kind of man he is he's
obviously he's a very loved and guide I
don't think there's a lot of prejudice
in him at all Joe Rogan's the man that
we think he is then he will address it
head-on and deal with it done simple the
only reason he might leave they are not
address it because once you start
rolling around with Alex Jones you start
to look just as [__] stupid assume
that cannot exist and Joe ignore it he's
a man who says he approaches all his
problems he deals with things head-on he
deals with big fighters [__] then you
need to just go cool I was wrong move on
so what else is there
Jay Paul got arrested went up to a capo
room saw flirted with them the rest of
effect I think I don't know what I
didn't see that for another video I got
a bit bored Jake I hope you are okay
moving on it turns out that Soulja Boy
and blac Chyna have been dating cause
blac Chyna is the mother to the baby of
Rob Kardashian that came out in the news
basically been going out for a couple
weeks and then people start saying well
they're not together anymore Soulja Boy
then tweets basically Soulja Boy just
said I just wanted to see how that [__]
feels we've all business sometimes as a
woman right and you saw about your shoot
field-mice blac Chyna isn't the type of
woman you wife up is it she is just a
Rob Kardashian man experience you know
an experience what like sort of air at
Alton Towers is I'm very much right I
mean you do at the once alright done
that no don't need to stay there anyway
she is now also said to be relieved and
glad the relationship is over she called
him immature anything is a little
immature I think she's a [__] where she
trapped Rob Kardashian like a piece of
[__] right I don't think he was great am
in him pictures of another guy's
shagging her at one point right after
she dumped him I don't think she
deserves to be trapped well by anyone
she's a [__] she doesn't sound like a
nice person I'll give you that blac
Chyna we wish you all the best you could
soldier boy we also wish you all the
best thought it was an idiot but you
kind of love him just a quick question
do you think he supermanned her right
facing the lobster I'm not done yet
No
[Music]
is huge isn't she must have to be really
hungry before she starts this shoe -
that microphone closer to the lobster oh
you're gonna find out boy today we have
the giant lobster the giant 15 pound
lobster you guys I am so excited I'm so
hungry this thing is massive it's huge
one thing Disney you were right to pull
me out this is 36 minutes long if she
can finish her [__] lobster in 36
minutes I'm gonna be impressed you
underestimated her she's licking her
[__] fingers now she doesn't even
tasted it yet oh she's doing a mukbang
right there's no reason why this person
cannot eat in a clean way like you've
got a lot of food to eat it doesn't mean
you have to eat it quick there's no one
who's going no wait see this woman eat a
lobster in half under half an hour
you've just said if she eats it in 36
minutes I'll be impressed
I'm not wait to see this I just don't
want someone to go yeah that woman a
lobster in under half an hour oh I don't
want to go yeah need to see that one's
going must watch this woman shove things
in her gaping hole all that or me what
slicing up that's all me you're gonna
see what she can do here she's eating
the entrails first wife enjoying it it's
like glugging a fine wine this woman's
glugging a lobster if you weren't on a
date and a woman wait get me the 15
pound lobster then ate it like this you
wouldn't be impressed I know you'd be
wondering what she'd do with you but you
wouldn't be impressed I would be
convinced she would [__] unbelievably if
she did it's decisive she keeps Timbits
out she hasn't even cares but most
people don't excuse me I have a little
something in my teeth sorry
this one just let you guys air Oh bill
lobster just a big old bird okay see
that isn't garlic sauce all answered and
I worked in a butcher's once and
honestly this is up there I've seen some
[__] this is really up there Frank isn't
it
yeah no one burps like that and then
goes excuse me you know go Oh whoopsie
they're disgusting it's like a garbage
compactor I bet you should give some
mean [__] I mean literally if she can
take all this a [__] must be nothing
this is not still huh you dumb [__] nice
a Roven can't see the screen and all run
from this hearing is oh my gosh whatever
look look at this Claro Fionn exactly
although I get the famous woman is small
I am so stuffed I'm so oh my gosh you
guys if you stick a pin in me I would
explode oh good yeah she almost finished
as a [__] thing mangoes well that
bloke I'm just really interested to see
what else is on her channel real quick
I'm not what's what are you gonna eat
more food
yeah what about the burger her
beautician does it must hate having to
do her cuticles what have you got under
here girl I got a little chicken little
Oh sir like do you remember the most
successful ship of all time that's right
the Titanic is being remade into a ship
which will now I think set sail in 2022
hey do you remember that massive
catastrophe sure let's remind everyone
about it would you want to go on that no
no that's what I'm saying all they've
got the destroyer gonna recreate
everything everyone will want to
photograph with the staircase well then
you get your luster sign at the
staircase you know can you look a bit
more like a prime fit Kate Winslet I'm
just gonna be straight up with you I
don't think so that loader
I don't think Kate Winslet's as pretty
as everyone says I remember watching a
video film being like I thought it would
look very nice with the red hair in all
she got them curves on it you know my
favorite line in Titanic and it is
embarrassing that I know a line from
Titanic but the bus that who's marrying
roars sorry I liked it and Hayley hotly
spoiler alert I don't lie to mom when
she's about to throw herself off the
Titanic because she doesn't want to
marry this guy and Chuck saves her guy
who arrests Jack yeah
is the father of true Geordi podcast
Gaston Portman and that's not my
favorite bit I just wanted to put that
out they won't have a connection in the
show right when he goes give us so many
20 should do it yeah she goes uh set the
going rate yeah for the woman you are
going to marry now this is the best line
of the movie are you ready for this Rose
is displeased what to do that's the best
life right okay have you ever wanted a
girlfriend called Rose no you can't do
that whenever a woman's annoyed at me I
was called she's displeased what to do
what you're saying is you aspire to be
like the bad guy in a film the bad guy
with all the money and all the power
right now is a complete dick well he
won't he lived yeah and ultimately
living is what you want I just I just
like this video this video is just funny
to me so this woman's doing parkour
right watch this parkour
she doesn't quite nail it oh no I fell
over okay that's bad that's bad it's
embarrassing isn't it
[__] [__] every time is funny you
know when you're naturally clumsy dawn
to parkour oh yeah I wanted you to see
this I feel like this is a little bit
weird do you know what I mean for sure
this is wait different current place and
different culture culture
no okay smart your mother's ass like
it's yours in Brazil they're much more
sort of physical with each other like
maybe is a sex thing but it's also like
our mum right so when he first did that
mm-hmm I thought he missed grab he
missed scrubbed and then he moves up but
then when he smacks her on feels like no
hand Moo see it also caress it but then
it goes back up again to you the other
there was a mistake but then you're like
no it's definitely not mistake these
marks are on the arses of you thanks her
name all your weird so this is the
Eubanks on this morning it's so awkward
isn't it like I would love it if he just
floored it and it might come off you can
tell that when it might come off it sort
of annoyed Chris a little bit he was
like I don't look quite as suave anymore
than everything he does and the fact
that he insists on wearing a [__]
police badge everywhere even when he's
not on duty real police officers they
take this [__] off at the end of the day
if you popped his [__] fire alarm on
it 3:00 in the morning he'd come Oh
pajamas on [__] police badge button
to his [__] PJs now his silk pajamas
with a [__] police budget angelov in
American I Kris I do work there with the
police force I'm a sergeant now an
official position by a court of law at
the Deputy Marshal of how is explaining
that as if someone's tried to degrade
what years and then he's like no no this
is real court of law when I wear this
it's saying sire of the people protect
and serve the people saying yes serve
the people yeah well it's actually
seeing Chris is you look like a bit of a
bellend me if my daughter gets hurt in
the community it's only a matter of
chance that it wasn't your daughter so
then it's only a matter of time so we
all must look after each other ah lovely
he says it's brilliant when he says it
like that you think
there are you are god you're all right
yeah that is brilliant I think that's a
nice way to finish what was some sad
moments on true news ultimately it went
from pedophiles to the police the police
the solution to the problem krisi fresh
new bunk on YouTube is coming for you
poodles yeah all right because it's only
as Chris says a matter of time so thanks
all for watching it's been good to have
you don't forget to head over to the
kick off Channel yeah if you haven't
subscribe to our football Channel and
you like a better football links in the
description below thanks for watching
like what Sousa